ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนผู้หญิงค่าวันนี้กูเอกขอยืนนะ
คะได้ค่ะครูเอ๋ตัวเองนั่งเห็นเท่านี้ตอน
นี้ยืน
ได้ค่ะโอเคอ่าเดี๋ยวขออีกนั่งเนี่ยนั่งมา
4 ชั่วโมง
นั่งเหนื่อยและเองยืน
ดีกว่าใช่ไหมคะถ้า
โอเคค่ะผู้หญิงทำอะไรนะคะผู้หญิงจะแช่
screen ก่อนนะคะจะได้เกรียนค่ะ
ใหญ่มากแล้วเขาเปลี่ยนสีกันนะคะมีสีให้
เราแค่นี้นะคะโอเคค่ะครูเอ๋
วันที่ได้ตั้งค่าวันที่วันนี้วันอะไรคะ
ผู้หญิงวันนี้วันพุธค่ะวันนี้วันพุธนะคะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 11 ค่ะวันที่ 11
นะคะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมเดือนพฤษภาคมปีพตเท่าไหร่คะอี
พ.ต.ต.
2556  5  5 ค่ะ
2565 นะคะค่ะแล้ววันนี้ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมง
คะเวลาอัน
3 โมง
19 นาทีค่ะ 2  3 โมง 19 นาทีพูดว่าบ่าย
ลูก 3 โมงไหมคะได้ค่ะบ่ายสามโมง 19 นาที
หรือ 3 โมง 19 นาทีนโอเคค่ะค่ะ
เดี๋ยวมีอะไร
วันนี้ครูหญิง
มีคำถามมาถามครูเอ๋ค่ะคำถามนะคะ
ตายผู้หญิงมีคำถามค่ะกูเอ๋คำถามถามว่า
อะไรคะคุณหญิงห้ามเกี่ยวกับน้ำหนักค่ะครู
เอ๋ผู้หญิงอยากรู้ครูเอ๋น่ะเท่าไหร่ล่ะคะ
น้ำหนักเป็นกิโลกรัมใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่
ถามครูเอ๋เอ๋หนักเท่าไหร่ไม่ถามนักเรียน
ไม่ได้ไม่เอานักเรียนจะโกรธนะเนี่ยขอ
เบอร์ใหม่ๆค่ะครูเอ๋นัดพี่หญิง
ถามใครถามครูเอ๋นี่แหละแต่ครูหญิงแล้วนะ
คะจะมีของอ่ะสมมุตินะพี่เอ๋หญิงนี่ 1  2
มีของ 2 อย่างค่ะ
แล้วก็จะถามครูเอ๋ว่าครูเอ๋คิดว่า
1 กับ 2 เนี่ยอันไหนหนัก
มากกว่าชาย
ผู้หญิงอาจจะถามครูเอว่า A  AB อันไหนน่ะ
หรือ A  B  C อันไหนเบา
หรือมีแค่หนัก
กับหนักกับเบาหวานหนักกับเบานะคะ zhang
สอบถามหนักกี่กิโลกรัมไม่ถามไม่ถามไม่ถาม
อ่ะอย่างเช่นอาจถ้าเป็นอันนี้ใช่ไหมคะนี้
เนี่ยเป็นน้ำพริกเผาใช้ค่ะน้ำพริกเผา
น้ำพริกเผานะคะอีกมุมหนึ่งค่ะ
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิงหมุนๆๆโอเคผู้หญิง
เปิดได้ไหมคะหนูเปิดเลยเหรอฮะไม่รู้มัน
กินได้หรือเปล่านะคะ
นานมากเปิดเปิดแล้วให้ดูขอไหมเมื่อกี้ผู้
หญิงดมดมเนี่ยหอมไหมคะอยู่หน้าเลย
เหม็น
แต่ไม่หอมกูเอกคิดหอมอ่ะผู้หญิงให้ดูได้
ไหมให้ดูให้ดูได้ไหมคะนี่ค่ะข้างใน
เรียกว่าน้ำหมอเขาชายขาสมมตินะกูเอ๋
ครูหญิงมี
น้ำพริกเผาแล้วก็อันนี้เนี่ยเป็น
อะไรอ่ะเป็นกาแฟค่ะอ๋อ
อย่ากาแฟพร้อมมีน้ำพริกเผา 1 อะไรคะ 1
กระปุก
ขวดหรือกระปุก
มึงไปเป็นขวดหรอ
บางทีพูดกระปุกบางทีพูดขวดเนาะใส่ค่ะน้ำ
พริกเผาก็พูดกระปุกเนาะจ่ายค่ะ
1 กระปุก
น้ำพริกเผาเนี่ยเซเว่นหนัก
แต่ถ้ากาแฟกาแฟ 1 ซองอันเนี้ยเบา 1 ซอง
เป่าเบาอันนี้น้ะอันนี้เบาแต่ว่านี่ไม่
ใช่คำถามนะคะอันนี้ครูพี่เก๋ดูก็เข้าใจ
แล้วค่ะต้อง
ยักษ์ยากค่ะคุยเอากาแฟดีกว่าครูเอ๋เนี่ย
ไม่ดื่มกาแฟค่ะ
ครูเอ๋คะครูหญิงมีกาแฟ 2 ซอง
ค่ะเดี๋ยว
โอยโอ๊ยโอ๊ย
เดี๋ยวอ่ะมือไหนมือขวามือซ้ายเนี่ยอันนี้
มือขวาค่ะสาวมือขวาเนี่ยผู้หญิงถือกาแฟ
ซองสีฟ้าใช่ไหมคะกำลังถือถือกาแฟซองสีฟ้า
มือซ้ายถือกาแฟซองสีเขียว
ไก่สองเขียวมีกาแฟ
2K คำถามค่ะอ่ะมีผู้ถามครูเอ๋คิดว่ากาแฟ
ซองไหนเนี่ยหนัก
หนัก
หนักมากกว่ากันซึ่งนั่นแหละค่ะ
ผู้หญิงเอากาแฟมาใกล้ๆกล้องอ่าเดี๋ยวก่อน
นะคะพี่ต้องปิดก่อนนะเดี๋ยวกูเอาดูอ๋อ
โอ้ยคู่เอกก็ไม่เห็นสิ
เห็นน่ะโอเคโอเคยังไม่เห็นไอ้ผู้หญิงเอา
เอากาแฟมาวางอยู่ใกล้กันอยากรู้อะไรสูง
อ๋อ
สีเขียวสูงกว่าเนาะใส่ค่ะอ่าโอเคดูข้าง
สร้างดูข้างๆ
ผู้หญิงเอาอันครับกันได้ไหม
ล่ะคะได้ใช่ๆกูอาจจะดูอะไรกว้างกว่า
ขออ้า
ฮะโอเค
ครูเอ๋คลิป
นักเรียนนักเรียนถ้วยครูเอ๋คิดสีฟ้าสี
เขียวหมี่ปีฟ้า
สีเขียวสีฟ้าสีเขียว
กาแฟสีอะไรหนักมากกว่าใส่ค่ะผู้หญิงคะ
กาแฟ
ซองสีสี
อะไร
2 สีเขียวเดี๋ยวครูหญิงรู๋ดูเองและเขา
ว่าซองฮะค่อยๆคิดอะไรอ่ะเดี๋ยวครูเอกคิด
ซองสีเขียวใช่ไหมผู้หญิงไม่เฉลยใช่ไหมคะ
เฉลยไหม
เฉลยแต่ให้ครูเอ๋ดูไงคะว่าซองสีเขียว
เนี่ยหนักเท่าไหร่หนอ
และก็อะคูเอดูตาย 2 สีเขียวเนี่ยหนัก
9 กรัม 9 กรัม
ๆๆ
ดู 2  4 ฟ้าเจ็ดกรัม
เฮ้ยคลิปกล้ำ
ขอโทษคิด
524 ฟ้าหนักอาหารหนักกว่าซองสีเขียว 1
กรัม
รู้สึกฉะนั้นเอาไม่เป็นไรมันยากใช่ไหมครู
เอ๋
ยาวๆเราอาหารเอาอาหารว่างเอกก็ไม่กินแล้ว
นะค่ะอ่ะครูหญิงมีน้ำหมอเขานะฮะ
น้ำพริกเผานะที่ให้ดูไปนั่นแหละค่ะน้ำ
พริกเผา
แล้วก็ก็อันนี้เป็น
ปลาทูน่ากระป๋องเนาะปลาทูน่ากระป๋องโอเค
มีราคานักเรียนนะปลาทูน่ากระป๋องเห็นไหม
คะจะมาแอบดูใช่ไหมว่าหนักเท่าไหร่
ทำไมรู้ไม่เห็นหรอกครูหญิงปิดเอาไว้แล้ว
อ่ะครูเอ๋คะค่ะ
ผู้หญิงนี่นะเพลงปิดเอาไว้นะคะเดี๋ยวกู
เห็น
ไม่เห็นมันไกลๆๆครูเอกคิดว่า
น้ำพริกเผา
กระปุกนี้นะหรือว่าขวดนี้นะคะกับอารา
ทูน่ากระป๋อง
อันไหนเบา
มีมุกฮะเบาเหล่าอาเดี๋ยวกูอีกสวย Shopping
ครูเอกคิดนะ
นักเรียนกินนักเรียนคิดถึงนักเรียนคิด
อะไรนักเรียนคิดว่าอันไหนเนี่ยเบาสวยเบา
บางเอกคิด
ปลาทูน่ากระป๋อง
เบาเบาๆ
ก็ต้องถ้าปลาถ้าครูเอ๋ถูกเกาะราชาทูน่า
กระป๋องเนี่ยก็น้ำหนักน้อยกว่า
น้ำพริกเผา
ให้ครบเฉลยดูน้ำพริกเผาหนักเท่าไหร่คะ
200 บาทใช่มั้ย
228 กรัมคะ
228 กะอา
อ้าอ้าว
เฮ้ยเดี๋ยวป้าชูเดิมมัน 300 กรัมใช่ไหม
มันเล็กมากเองคิดอะไรเงี้ยเอ้อ
อ้าปลาทูน่าก
เอ๋ปลาทูน่ากระป๋องหนักเท่าไหร่คะ
80  g  r เธอเองโทรได้ไหม
น้ำคะแดง
เย้ปลาทูน่าเนี่ยเบานะคะเบาน้ำพริกเผา
หนักนะไอ้เก่งมากค่ะ
ของกินโอเคกู x เก่งใช่ไหมเอาอันนี้ดี
กว่าเดี๋ยวต้องซ่อนคู๋ก่อนนะไม่ให้กูเอ๋
เห็นอะไรเนี่ยเอ๋กินได้หรอกพี่ก็ไม่รู้นะ
คะอันนี้มันมันเป็น
หัดของนักเรียนน่ะอ้ะและโฉมอ๋อรู้จักรู้
จักเนาะเป็นอาร์ติโช๊คแล้วก็อยู่ในน้ำ
อาหารอะดิโช้คแล้วก็อีกอันนึงเป็นถั่วดำ
กระป๋องโอ้ยอยากรัก
ครูเอ๋คะเอกขอดู
ถั่วดำอะดิโชคโอเคค่ะดาว
ยกถั่วดำขึ้นนะค่ะให้เห็นเห็นถั่วดำใกล้ๆ
เดินแล้วนะคะพี่เอาลงเล่นกันๆหน่อยเออ
ยาซะโอเคคือครูเอ๋ไม่รู้ข้างในอ่ะถั่วดำ
เนี่ยเป็นน้ำหรือมีอะมีน้ำมีน้ำมีอดีต
โช้คมีน้ำซอยมีน้ำมีตัวดำ
มีน้ำโอเคมีน้ำเหมือนกันค่ะครูเอ๋ถ้ามี
น้ำโอเคมีน้ำเหมือนกันครูเอ๋ครู a คิดว่า
อันไหน
เบาเบาใช่ไหมเข้าเบ้า
อาร์ติโช้คหรือถั่วดำเบานับๆเบาๆนะเบาไม่
ไม่ใช่หนักเบา
อาครูเอ๋คิด
อยากนะญาติกูเอกคลิป The นะ
อาร์ติโช้คเบากว่าถั่วดำครูคิดอาร์ติโช้ค
ถูกคอขาว
คุณ
ครูเอ๋อาติโช๊คเนี่ยนะคะนานาอันนี้น่า
จะต้องเขียนนะว่ามองไม่เห็นเลยค่ะอ๋อโอเค
กูจะเขียนให้ก็ได้ถึงจะให้ก็ได้ค่ะนิด
หน่อยอ่ะ
อาติโช๊คเนี่ย
หนัก
415 กรัมหนัก 415 กรัมแล้วถั่วดำราคา
ทัวร์ดำน้ำหนัก 4
425 กรัม
10 กรัม
อะดิโช๊คเบาถั่วดำอ๋องั้นอาตีโช้คก็เบา
กว่าถั่วดำไปสาวอดีตซุปเบากว่าถั่วดำถั่ว
ดำน่ะกว่าอะดิโช้คนะคะอายเวลา 22 คะแนนคะ
นักเรียนเชิญตอนสีก็
อาติโช๊คถั่วดำไม่ชัวร์ดำหนักอาร์ติโชค
เปล่ากิ่งมาก
อ่ะต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ต่อไปอะไรคะนี่ค่ะครู
เหตุสนุกคนเดียว
นะเขาผู้หญิงติดอันนี้แป๊บนึงแล้วอ้ะได้
แล้วค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ชอบกินสปาเก็ตตี้ไหม
โอเค
อ่ะครูหญิงเนี่ยมี
Wave มี
อีกผู้หญิงปิดก่อนนะคะ
มีสปาเก็ตมีเส้นสปาเกตตีสองแบบมีเส้นตรง
แต่ก็เป็น
ครับโครงเล็กๆใช่ค่ะคำๆเพลงลินี่นี่นะคะ
N1 คะค่ะ
แล้วตอนนี้เป็นเส้นเกลียวไหม
เปรียว
พาสต้าเนาะหมอ
ว่าเป็นอะไรนะมาต่อโทนี
นักเรียนเนาะคนไทยเรดสปาเก็ตตี้ผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงอยู่ไหนคะตอนเนี้ย
ประเทศไทยมีอาทิตย์โช้คมีถั่วดำมี
สปาเก็ตตี้ทำไมผู้หญิงไม่มี
ไม่มีอะไรนะยาธาตุน้ำขาวแบบไทยน่ะไม่มี
น้ำไงผู้หญิงไม่มีมันไม่มีน้ำหนักไงพูด
เอ๋
ถึงเป็นน้ำอันนี้มีน้ำหนักนะคะ
ครูเอ๋คะเส้นสปาเก็ตตี้ประเภทที่นะคะเส้น
สปาเก็ตตี้แบบเส้นตรงก็ขับเส้นพลาซ่าล้อ
มักกะโรนีแบบเกลียวนะคะครูเอ๋เอ๋คิดว่า
อันไหนนะ
หนักน้ำหนักหนักมากกว่าใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
หนักมากกว่าหนักอันไหนหนักมากกว่าอุ้ยผู้
หญิงตอบได้เลยค่ะเส้นมะกะโรนีค่ะอันนี้
ใช่ไหมคะเกี่ยวเป็นเกลียวเส้นเกลียว
เดี๋ยวครูหญิงให้ครูเอ๋ดูว่าเส้นเกลียว
หนักเท่าไหร่เปรียบผิดแน่เลย
ค่า 500 กรัมนะคะ
500 กรัมดูเส้นตรงนะแม็คเวท
เดี๋ยวๆทำใจก่อนๆผู้หญิงหัวเราะแล้วคู๋ใจ
ไม่ดี
หนูดูนะคะว่าเส้นตรงมีเท่าไหร่เกรดต้อง
ไม่ชอบผู้หญิงคำถามนี้อยากจะฆ่าผู้หญิงนะ
ได้
ฉันเซ็น
500 กรัมโคเย็น
kuai อันไหนหนักกว่านะคะ
ไม่มีนักกว่ามหนักเท่ากันอันนี้หลักเทา
กัน
แกล้งโปรเอสนุกมากเลย
อ่ะไม่มีแล้วนะไม่มีเท่ากันแล้วไม่มีไม่
มีแล้วไม่มีแล้วไม่เป็นไรนักเรียนครูหญิง
อาจคิดให้นักเรียนรู้จักคำที่ว่าเท่ากัน
นะไทยค่ะ 500 กรัม 500 กรัมเนี่ยเข้ากัน
ได้หนักเท่ากันนะคะเท่ากันนะไม่มีนะและ
เบากว่าไม่มีเท่ากันอ่ะต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋
เท่ากับเสียไม่มีแล้วไม่มีแล้วไม่มีแล้ว
ไม่มีแล้วหมดแล้วมีอันเดียวนะคะอันเดียว
นะคะอยากได้ไหมคะเดี๋ยวเสร็จแล้วผิดให้
ได้นะคะแป้งแพนเค้กอ๋อ
ไม่เคยเปิดเลยนะครับตัวเอง
หรือของฝรั่งเนาะ
ผู้หญิงไม่มีอาหารไทย
f  f  a ผู้หญิงหาที่บ้านเอาอะไรมาเล่น
เกมกับครูเอ๋
แป้งแอนเค้กนะคะเป็นขนาดนั้นเนี่ยดูนะเอา
ดาวผู้หญิง
ใช่ไหมคะค่ะอยู่แค่ข้างในก่อนผู้หญิงและ
พาสต้าอยู่ในอะไรคะในซองในถุงในถุงอ๋อ
เป็นถุงนะคะกูสุขแต่หมู่บ้านแพนเค้กอยู่
ในอยู่ข้างในกล่องกินข้าวสาไทยก็ได้ค่ะจะ
ได้รู้ว่าอยู่ประเทศไทยนะคะ
อยู่ในกล่องแอร์ครูเอ๋แล้วก็ครูหญิงก็มี
มีอะไรคะ
Baking  Soda
ภาษาไทยก็คือ Baking  Soda ใส่ค่ะไปกิน
โซดาอยู่ในอะไรคะครูเอ๋ในซองอยู่ในซองนะ
คะอ่ะ Song  Back  Baking  Soda แล้วก็
กล่องแป้งแพนเค้ก
อันไหนเบา
เบาๆใช่มั้ยน้องกว่าอันไหนเบากว่าเออยาก
นะ
ดูไม่ได้เพราะว่ากล่องใหญ่แต่ข้างในมีซอง
อีก
อาทิผู้หญิงแกะไหม
แต่ไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรไม่ใช้
อยู่แล้ว
แกะแต่ยังไม่ได้แกะเลยนะคะนักเรียนใหม่
มากๆน่าจะหมดอายุแล้วก็
ได้อันนี้แป้งแพนเค้กอันนี้ Baking  Soda
ผู้หญิงใจดี
ใจดีเดี๋ยวตัวเองคิดว่าอันไหนเบากว่าเอ่อ
เบาก็ได้
Baking  Soda เบากว่าคุยแน่ใจเหรอคะ
แน่ใจค่ะรุ่นเอ๋เอ๋ชั่วไหมชั่วค่ะ
เมื่อกี้ฉันกล่องเนี่ยยังไม่ชัวร์ไม่แน่
ใจแต่พอผู้หญิงแกะกล่องแล้วก็ดึงถุงใช่มะ
ดึงถุงขึ้นมาแล้วก็เห็นกูเองแน่ใจอ่ะเธอ
แกล้งน่ะน่ะ Baking  Soda เบาขอเพลงถาม
ว่าอันไหนเบากว่าเส้นไหนก๊อป Baking  Soda
เบากว่าค่ะ
เฉลยถูกค่ะครูเอ๋
ว่า Baking  Soda เนี่ยหนักเท่าไหร่คะ 300
กรัมค่ะ 300 กรัมส่วนแป้งแพนเค้กหนัก
400 กรัม
ก็ Baking  Soda เบากว่าแป้งแพนเค้กไทย
ค่ะ
แล้วเนี่ย weight  3  4 คะแนนแล้วไม่ผิด
ก็ผิด 2 ผิดข้อเดียวกับเท่ากัน 2 ข้อ a
Break  Wing เปลี่ยนก็ได้ค่ะครูบอกว่า
ผู้หญิงทำไมมีแต่อาหารฝรั่งชายใช่อ่ะแต่
พี่ต้องปิดก่อนนะคะเดี๋ยวครูเห็นอ้ะครู
หญิงมี
ผงอะไรนั่งเล่นนะคะปลาสไลด์
ปลาแผ่นแผ่นมาแผ่นแล้วก็สาหร่ายอยู่ในซอง
เหมือนกันคือ
จะมีเสียงเล็กกับซองใหญ่นะไม่ล่ะสาหร่าย
เนี่ยซองเล็กปลาแผ่นเนี่ยซองใหญ่
ปลาแผ่นก็เบาๆสาหร่ายก็เบาเบาๆคือเองคิด
ว่าอันไหนน่ะกว่า
หนักกว่าเหรอคะหนักกว่าอันไหนนะสาหร่าย
ปลาแผ่นสาหร่ายปลาแผ่นสาหร่ายปลาแผ่นอะไร
นะหนักใช่ไหมคะค่ะอันหนึ่งซองเล็กอันนึง
พี่น้องใหญ่ 2 เล็กอันนี้ซองใหญ่อ๋อผู้
หญิงกลับหลังไม่ได้อ้ะกับหลังนี่ครับอ้า
อาอา
ๆอันไหนหนักผู้หญิงจับจับๆปลาแผ่นได้ไหม
อ่ะอยากจะดูอ่ะ
เฮ้ยเอาข้างบนไม่มีนะมีข้างล่างให้พี่
เด็กผู้เยาว์ตามซองนะพี่เอ๋
ซองเขียนหนักเท่าไหร่
[เพลง]
ยากอะกูเห็นมันไม่ยากขนาดนั้นหรอก
เฮ้ยเปลี่ยนไม่ต้องคิดเยอะๆคิด
หนักใช่มั้ยน่าจะใช้ปะหน้าได้สาทายๆ
สาหร่าย
โกหกหรือผิดคะ
พิชช่าๆ
อากูเอดูว่าปลานัดเท่าไหร่
880 กรัม 80 กรัมใช่ไหมคะค่ะครูเอ๋ดูว่า
สาหร่ายหนักเท่าไหร่
13.5 กรัม
Oil ครูเอกคิดมากๆเนาะแล้วก็เอ๋ไม่ต้อง
คิดมากๆนะคะก็ลาแผ่นหนักกว่างู of ธรรมดา
ปลาก็เบาเบาๆโอเคไง a  song มันใหญ่หลายๆ
ผู้หญิงหัวเราะอ่ะกูเอกก็ได้คิดคู่หญิง
ซิกแซ็กด้วย
เอาเอาแบบไม่ยากดีกว่าครูเอ๋เอ๋จะได้แบบ
เพราะครูอันนี้ครูเอ๋ก็อาจจะรู้จักนะคะ
อ่าผู้หญิงนี่อันนี้เป็นอัลมอนด์ค่ะ
อัลมอนด์นะที่อยู่ในซองนะ 504 ล้านอ้าว
เห็นแล้วหรอคะเอามาให้ซื้อบ่อยๆไม่ใช่ตัว
เองใช่
ก็คือ
อีกหนึ่งอัน
450 กรัมอันนี้เป็น
ผู้มีไหนอย่างนะมีเม็ดมะม่วงหิมพานต์มี
อัลมอนด์แต่ว่านี่มันอยู่ในอะไรอ่ะครูเอ๋
อ่านายในๆในกระปุกกันแหละเนาะจะเป็น
กระจุกใหญ่ๆๆนะครับ
อยู่ในกระปุกกับอยู่ในซองค่ะอันไหน
เบากว่าบ่าว
อัลมอนด์เขาเบากว่าไม่รู้ดู
อันนี้เห็นเข้าใจ
กูหาครูเอ๋
คู่กรรมหรือว่า
500  400 กรัม
400 กรัมนะคะนี่
400 กรัมนะคะแต่กระปุกนี้นะคะครูเอ๋
กิโลกรัมไม่ถึงเขาไปถึง
เท่าไหร่
1130 กรัม
กรัมกว่าหยัดมากกว่าเยอะนะ
เก่งมากเรายังมีเวลาใช่ไหมคู๋คิดว่า
กูได้อีกหนึ่งเข้านะคะว่าอันนี้อันนี้ของ
เหมือนกัน
นะคะเขาเห็นต้องปิดก่อนนะคะเป็นงาขาวนะคะ
ครูเอ๋
ขาวโอเคยาสาวอันนี้เป็นไงขาวนะอยู่ในซอง
อันนี้นี้เป็นงาขาวเหมือนกันแต่นี้เนี่ย
บทค่ะ
นะงานอยากนิดหน่อยนะเนี่ยอยากกินหน่อยยาก
นิดหน่อยหัวใจใสๆค่ะงานขาวันนี้นะจับงาน
ขาวบดนะคะ
อันไหน
หนักกว่าหนักนะ
งาขาวค่ะงาขาวงาขาวหนักกว่านั้นกว่านี้
ใช่ไหมคะงาขาวข่าว
เฉลยกูไอ้ถูกมั้ยไม่ถูกมั้ยคู๋
ผิดค่ะอะไร
อ่ะครูเอ๋ดูว่างาขาวบทหนักเท่าไหร่คะ 55
กรัม 55 กรัม
งาขาว
น่ะเท่าไหร่คะอ่ะ
เหรียญ 50 กรัมโห
อะไรจะคุยเก่งนะ
สายๆดูอยากดูย่อสีคล้ายใส่
แต่ครูเอ๋เก่งมากนะคะคู๋รู้อันไหนนาดอัน
ไหนเบานะนักเรียนคิดว่าครูหญิง VA ไกลง
อัดกว่า
โอเคคลิปนี้ไม่เฉลยใช่มั้ยไม่เฉลยค่ะไม่
เฉลยไม่บอกนะคะนักเรียนน้องคิดเองนัก
เรียนดูเหอะจะดูว่าเข้าใจเราไหม
อ่าไม่รู้
อยากเห็นแค่นี้ไงไม่เห็นแค่นี้นักเรียน
ไม่รู้นักเรียนคิดผู้หญิงกับผู้เห็นน่ะ
ใช่ไหมใครน่ะดีกว่าหลักมากกว่าอ่านัก
เรียนก็คอมเม้นข้างล่างนะคะ
เราไม่บอก
เดี๋ยวเราถ้าใครพากย์ไทยถูกสิ่งป้องเราจะ
ให้หัวใจ
แล้วจะให้พูดภาษาไทยเก่งๆนะคะแต่ว่า
วีดีโอนี้คิดว่าหมดเวลาแล้วหมดแล้วค่ะ
เดี๋ยวก็เจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
ค่ะบ๊ายบาย